do you think that as a culture we are
continuing to become more and more
polarized in our views i mean it looks
that way
right but
is it productive yeah
well it's definitely not productive and
you can tell just by i mean i'm living
in nashville right nashville is pretty
conservative talking to people and
they're pretty conservative so you have
people and they're like oh yeah you know
if
you know some of those covid bills or
like liberals come over here like we
have our guns like oh i was just going
to say they have guns and they hunt
yeah exactly and then you go to
you know areas in california and they're
like oh you know like rednecks
rednecks with guns like there's no they
you know they don't have any brains they
don't know what they're talking about
they just follow fake news right and
they just
i don't know how those
like i don't know how those p type of
people can get along
yeah i just think it's getting worse i
think the polarization is getting worse
and it gets harder and harder for people
to hear each other
and be open-minded and i think a remedy
is being able to have that conversation
but i think it's fascinating i think
we're in a we're just like cultures in
this place that's not getting seemingly
not getting better it's getting worse at
least from
um
you know polarized perspectives and um
division it's like you know
uh divide and conquer takes on a new
year like you'd say i used to think
divide and conquer was all about you
know uh divide up the work and we all
get done more done but divide and
conquer is far more about like when
people can't agree you actually suppress
the whole thing and then someone else
can be in charge
do you think things were getting better
before coven
not that it matters now but yeah i don't
i don't think so i think that it's
probably been either
i think it's steady i don't think it was
better before co it was better than
before covid but i think that also
sometimes what ends up having to happen
is there has to be like such a huge
swing another direction to kind of
get people to
take stock and have a look at everything
and you know when something is so in
your face you end up having to finally
look at it and make a decision for
yourself
and um so i think that and i i
personally think that we're being asked
to look within and use our own inner
guidance and our own
emotional body as a more of an indicator
of truth versus you know the media
outlet or the newspaper or the
television program
or anything like that because we're just
having a hard time struggling we're
struggling with what's real and what's
not so
um but i don't think it was better
i i agree with what you said i think it
wasn't getting better yeah okay from
from my point of view for that it at
least in canada it looked like
thing and that could have been because
of my dad and all the controversy that
happened with him in like 2016 2017 but
i thought like 2018 2019 i thought
things were kind of calming down like i
thought we were hearing
about less fewer problems but then kovid
skyrocketed everything
i think every four years we get a
problem you know every four years we get
the great divider right like the color
divider and you know people like tv gets
obnoxious and there's ads on tv all day
about your local government or your you
know or national government with
president and you know
biden was a divider and trump was a
divider and you know like seemingly more
than normal
yeah
i think your point too about having to
look within kind of for guidance is a is
a smart
point because
i think people underestimate the value
of intuition
right and like um i had a hard time
wrapping my
mind around intuition because i always
thought about things like logically
whatever that means right whatever i
could actually factually see and then
kind of balancing that out in my head
and then
even though i had this gut instinct most
of the time where it was like okay
logically this makes sense but my god's
like pulling me in the other direction
real hard so what's what's going on
there and i think what happens is people
are really good at recognizing patterns
that they can't put into words
and so if you get this feeling where
you're like no something's off it's
because you've identified a whole bunch
of patterns out there
and you haven't
figured it out enough
i guess to put it into words
uh
so i'd say intuition is definitely
i at least undervalued it and now that
i've been kind of going more off no no i
feel like like i'm sure this is right in
my body and i don't know if women are
better at that than men or if people
just
kind of i think i stuffed it down and
ignored it for a long time without
valuing it but my life's definitely been
going better since i started being like
no my gut's saying do this i'll just go
for it
that's good what are some what are some
experiences where you look back and
think if i would have listened to this
this would have been different
relationships mostly i think yeah being
like you know i can't think about it it
doesn't make sense in my head but it
doesn't feel good and i guess
relationships are an easy thing to point
out because that's where you get a lot
of that instinct
but i'd say
probably relationships and then some
business
opportunities that i thought were a bad
idea that were
that i was like but kind of maybe more
pushed into
because there was no law i couldn't come
up with an explanation about why it was
a bad idea right like this just doesn't
feel right which is not a good argument
if you're if you're trying to make your
argument it's my intuition it's just not
a good argument especially if you're
talking to a man they're like yeah yeah
see the numbers yeah yeah exactly
exactly and i'm generalizing like i
always feel like you know obviously i
had a very long conversation about
polarizing so we're kind of i'm using
generalities here but men tend to be a
little bit more um analytical a little
bit more by the numbers a little bit
more a little bit more head space
instead of body and um and yeah i'm sure
talking to a guy and saying i don't know
dude just doesn't feel right let's do
this you know let's let's pull out
that doesn't go over well yeah and i
think i think the fact that
you know generally speaking men are well
at least known for being better you know
thinking about things in numbers like
that i think that's part of the reason i
kind of dampened down my feelings as
well
you know growing up and probably as a
in my 20s
which was me know my entire life so i'd
say early 20s but i probably you know
whenever i had this feeling i was like
well if i can't
put it into words it doesn't matter
and it took me until i i think i was 28
maybe or maybe 27 27 or 28 before i was
like you know what that does matter and
maybe focusing on it will actually
improve my life because maybe
it was until i thought maybe i was
picking up on patterns that i recognized
but couldn't put into words and that's
what intuition is i don't even know if
that's right or not but
yeah i think the fact that that numbers
and thinking about things logically are
more is more associated with men made me
dampen down that kind of part of me
yeah i think patterns or frequency
i think of a lot of things in terms of
frequency
the old nikola tesla famous quote if you
want to know the secrets of the universe
think in terms of energy vibration and
frequency yeah yeah i've seen that okay
okay tell me what that means
just that everything is an energy like
we are an energy everything has an
energy and so
um and then understanding in quantum
physics we're not dealing with the
things that can be seen and that
everything is connected and quantum
entanglement is the
word for that
and that we can we also so we can really
feel things even though you can't see
the connection you're there's threads
connecting there's energetic connections
and that we're energy and so we're kind
of creating wave patterns and these wave
patterns interact interact with each
other
being other people
and so we're getting
feedback on our surrounding on our on on
what we're dealing with we're getting
feedback on that and i think that that
can happen at a distance or right next
to each other
um yeah because it's energetic and it's
all that quantum physics stuff that i'm
fascinated with but definitely don't
understand well enough
um but yeah i think you're right you're
you're picking up on patterns but
because the pattern could be a pattern
of frequency
um okay i like that
i like that a lot i don't understand
that either but there's definitely
something to that because you have it
happens when you have conversations with
people too right you have a conversation
with something and something's just off
you're like this is off and nothing
seems to be going wrong but something is
not good here right and it and then you
can have a conversation with someone or
be near someone where it's like this is
comfortable
and i always was like maybe it's like
smell or i don't know what it is exactly
but
it's weird
where do you feel like you pick up more
of your nature your inherent nature
we talked a little bit about parents but
like they're kind of the foundation for
all of our
all of our good and all of our bad and
all of our all of our own patterns um
are you more i'm guessing you're more
like your dad because you know from what
i understand about your mom and my
watching things and listening is that
she's pretty and she's pretty into the
spiritual intuitive realm and
um and so you know being analytical is
not necessarily her nature so and i you
strike me as someone that's a little bit
more analytical
yeah i would say probably
i think maybe the older i get the more
i recognize parts of my mom in me but
i'd say
yeah it is cool it is cool um but i'd
say probably like 70 percent dad like
i'm part of the reason
i've been running his business is
because when
when something's off i can you know i
can look at something and say this is
not gonna be okay with him
right
this is not gonna be okay with him and
it's spot on all the time and it's it's
anything from you know
business deals
to thumbnails
or to how something's written
right um where i'm like that's off and
he's gonna pick up on that or that
doesn't sound right and it's gonna bug
him it's mostly that like that's gonna
bug him
you